donc si tout le monde gouverne avec tout
le monde ce sera qui l'opposition il y
aura forcément des gens à droite qui
ceux qui seront pas dans la majorité y
aura des gens à gauche et resteront pas
dans la peur on a un ce soir 400 députés
aux alentours de 400 députés la
république en marche mais sur cinq cent
soixante dix ans ça fait pas beaucoup ce
sont les citoyens qui décident
là tout simplement et je crois que nos
concitoyens ont fait le choix de donner
une majorité forte à emmanuel macron
c'est ça la réalité
on a vécu d'autres périodes qui au
niveau du travail législatif ont montré
parfois que c'était très compliqué de
diriger le pays
nos concitoyens en ont tiré les
enseignements de sa et veulent que le
pays soit dans la stabilité et que ce
pays puisse être transformée et pour
cela baisser donne les moyens de le
faire ça donne les résultats qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui avec quand même un
regret c'est que on a tellement annoncé
que la vague aller allait se réaliser
que finalement peut être aussi on à
démobiliser une partie de notre
électorat en fin de 2 l'électorat en
général et donc on se retrouve avec
quatre autres participations quand même
qui est faible et ça les uns et les
autres
quelles que soient nos opinions on ne
peut pas se réjouir une situation comme
celle là est donc au deuxième tour il
faudra beaucoup plus de mobilisation que
ce qu'on a ce à quoi on a assisté au
premier tour